Allo die Xion Hallo Christoph Kolumbus
ski-doo meine Frage an dich Bushido
du warst damals bei Aggro Berlin mich
interessieren warum Back Home Berlin
verlassen hast gar Streit mit Sido oder
unser eigenes Ding machen
vielen dank für die Antwort Schau
ja meint er sehr verehrter freuen sich
auf das er nahm ich mitbekommen aber
erheblich von den hier nochmal ans Herz
legen dass du dich vielleicht ein wenig
besser informieren wo das Verbot
wichtige Frage noch nicht beantworten
Nein es gibt ein Buch in dem das
ausführlich erklärt wurde ein Film in
dem es auch teilweise dem Meistbietenden
Jahren von Interviews von ihr
unvermittelt durch Sommer durch das
schöne Internet und anderswo auch
fündig dabei handelt es sind die die
Frage einfach seba taktisch